well everybody welcome to the fourth
image recognition and manipulation
tutorial video in the last video we were
breaking down the array and figure out
exactly how that is structured and now
in this video we're actually gonna begin
working with the image so just like I
was kind of saying in the last video
most people can't just like look at an
array and be like oh okay I see what's
going on so and some steps along the way
it's going to be important for us to
actually visualize what we're doing
because as time goes on when you use
some basic skills to either simplify or
even modify that image and if stuff
isn't working right the first time
through like a lot of times if you're
trying out something new it's not going
to work like the first time you think it
up right you kind of need to keep
tweaking it until you get it just right
the way that you want it and if you
can't see it visually it's really hard
if you understand like what you've done
with the image so to make sure we're
doing everything right we actually want
to see what the program itself is seeing
so what we're going to be using is
matplotlib to plot it up and show us
what we're looking at so and you could
obviously reconvert like whatever you've
changed back to an image and save the
image and then you wouldn't even have to
do any of this but for the ease of
working it into our program I think it's
best to just put it in the matplotlib
the first time through and matplotlib is
pretty easy to deal with so that's what
we're going to be doing so just say
import Matt plot Lib PI plot as p LT and
then we'll bring this up there and now
what we're going to want to do is
instead of printing it out let's do PLT
mo so it's just like basically show
image and then what do we want to show
we want to show is and then let's just
do plot show save that and run it and
you should have a little pop-up here and
now we can see that we've got a
black dot and we got a green dot okay so
if we close out of this and we just did
dot dot PNG so not dot n dot run that
and now you see we've got you know like
the solid ish black tie even though it
kind of goes out but what makes it
useful especially down the line is you
can see where like what part in the grid
this pixel is and there might be some
other image imports with Python as far
as bringing up an image and using it
maybe they don't have like the blurred
lines like their edges like this one
does but at least for the ease of
matplotlib I want to use it and also
we're not silent we're we need it
perfect like we just kind of want to
visualize what we've done to this image
so anyway let me close out of that and
that is basically bringing up within
matplotlib obviously let me bring it one
more time just show you guys with map
plot live like you can kind of view and
change the size of Matt plot live and
there's a bunch of other things that you
can do like you can click this thing and
you can like zoom into that spot if you
wanted to get really close to it nice
and if you get lost like this you can
just hit this home button and it takes
you back home and then if you were like
no I don't want to go home I want to go
back you can get back to previous view
or you go back forward and all and so on
or you can grab the axes and move it
around like this and that's about it you
can do some stuff here this just changes
the size of the plot as far as it is on
a figure and like the width basically
like how far is away from the edges or
from other subplots on this figure but
we're not too worried about that right
now so I'm learning to get into that if
you want to know more about Matt plot
living graphing in Python I have tons of
tutorials there so check those out so
I'm going to close out of that and that
is how we are going to view the image
after we've maybe made some changes to
the image so like he loses part in the
video series as always thanks for
watching